the Joe Rogan experience it gets down to
political and social issues and it gets
down to the heavy ones things like
abortion and war and you know freedom of
religion and then these these things I
think are the ones where we should all
just be communicating as calmly and as
you know as objectively as possible and
we should discourage this this tribal
perspective discourage this idea of
being married to your own ideas and and
trying to win these arguments yeah which
you see in Congress which you see in
political campaigns which you see in
television news is a [ __ ] dumpster
fire every single time they have the
panel with the three people it's just
why I can't watch it
it's nonsense yeah thank you for your
time what did you what what waste is
this people shouting over people you
never find out what the [ __ ] anybody
really believes just hear their their
their talking points blurted and vomited
out right and this asks the news what's
actually happening is completely lost
and it's so it's it's so limited and
this is how a lot of us are getting our
view of the world yeah and I feel like
things are changing I think the world is
a different place and it was even just
ten years ago
I think getting said to I think humans
are different I think we just we're not
aware of how much all this conversation
on all of our analyzing the world around
us has shifted over the last decade or
so people are looking I feel like people
are looking for for the facts they're
looking for more information they are
less likely to just accept at face value
what they're seeing on TV or what
they're hearing which I think is is a
positive thing and I think I think we do
need to look at the leadership of this
country to to set this culture for civil
discourse for making it making it okay
and encouraging actually those kinds of
conversations and that's where if you
look at it you watch c-span one night
when you can't fall asleep you'll see in
the floor of Congress you've got the
Democrats who are all
sitting on one side you've got the
Republicans all sitting on the other
side and unfortunately not often enough
do you see intermingling in conversation
and people going to the other side of
the aisle and after getting getting to
know people that was something that when
I first got elected I was told look as a
new member of Congress serving in the
minority with Republicans in charge
coming from a small state like Hawaii
you will never get anything done
so just accept it just accept that
reality that you're not gonna get
anything done wait several years or
whatever but one of the first things
that I did was I got to get to know
people I got to make friends so I my my
mom and dad their small business owners
and they had this macadamia nut toffee
business and so I called home I said hey
mom can you make 434 boxes of your
toffee for every single member of
Congress all the Democrats all the
Republicans she's like wow that's a
great idea yeah sure I'd be happy to and
then I said oh I got one more one more
request can you make a bigger box 435
bigger boxes of toffee for the staff of
every member of Congress because they're
the ones who make [ __ ] happen and she
said okay guys gonna take me a little
bit longer but yes I think that's a
great idea so you know I started writing
handwritten notes to every one of my
colleagues introducing myself and as we
started delivering these little gifts of
Aloha to their offices it was amazing
how quickly I saw while on the House
floor casting votes I'd have Republican
chairman of powerful committees making
their way across from the Republican
side to the Democratic side saying thank
you so much I really appreciate it was
delicious I need to get more from you
because I ate it all I got to take some
home to my wife or my husband and then
saying tell me what's going on in Hawaii
tell me what issues your constituents
are worried about I'm the chairman of
the Transportation Committee the
Agriculture Committee or whatever it is
let me know how we can work together
just that one small outreach of Aloha
open the doors to these relationships
that enabled me to be able to pass my
first piece of legislation like my first
six months
as a member of Congress from a small
state in the minority as a Democrat and
it's because just treating people with
respect treating people with Aloha and
saying yeah we can disagree even on nine
out of ten things but on that tenth
thing like hey let's talk let's get
something done
was that eye-opening for you and did you
at that moment in time realize like hey
I not only can I make an impact here I
can do this the way I want to do it yes
I can be a kind person and reach out and
yeah I mean and I don't have to listen
to these people that are entrenched
exactly it directly disproved what we
were told in those first days as new
members of Congress in Washington and
further affirmed what I already knew
both from what I learned from Senator
Akaka what I knew from growing up in
Hawaii with the Aloha spirit that this
this ability to transcend all of the
superficial divisive nests
whether it be based on politics like you
said or religion or race or ethnicity or
or any of these other things is what has
the power to bring us together as a
country